I don't think you know what you think
you know baby but baby don't you think
that I know what I know maybe baby I
know what you think that I don't know I
know I know I know I know I know I know
I know that you don't think I know that
I know what I know I don't know what you
think I think you know I don't better
know what you don't think I know I know
I know I know baby I know that you don't
know what I know
really I know that you don't know what I
know
you
[Music]
I don't know what I think but I know
what I know but you think that you know
what I knew that you don't that I know
what you think
I know I know I know I know
I know that you don't think I think that
I know
I don't know what you think I think you
think you know I don't but I know what
you don't think I know I know I know I
know baby I know that you don't know
what
baby I know that you don't know what
[Music]
that song only has 10 words in it and
yes I've been struck down by the evil
goddess influenza do you remember the
tiny chicken if you remember the tiny
chicken and you've been with us for a
long time
the tiny chicken has returned and it's
laying it little tiny chicken eggs in my
brain I'm there liquid didn't coming out
of my nose I wrote that to import song
as part of the masters of song fools
songwriting challenge and I'm submitting
it today and it will be up with a bunch
of other 10 word songs at Quickstop
entertainment calm on Thursday if you
want to check those out I did what you
all to know one thing though like
there's some amazing ventriloquist's in
the world but none of them can do this
I'm not actually a ventriloquist also I
wanted to mention that there is
something very sort of strange and cool
and amazing going on with this thing
that I've been following called this is
not Tom calm this is not Tom calm was a
bunch of really cool riddles but the
riddles and the challenges are very
rewarding when you get them and it seems
to be taking a turn for the awesome so
this is not Tom calm if you are
interested in ways to wile away the time
while being entertained and also uh
fascinated so if you want hours of
amusement banging your head against your
desk and then saying oh I don't suggest
doing it while on nyquil that makes
things more difficult I have to go to
sleep and do my taxes I don't know if I
can do both those things at the same
time but I'm gonna try